on voit qu'il ya quatre phénomènes de
régulation sociale qui se met en place
quasiment systématiquement le premier
qui évoquait l instant stéphanie gibeau
c'est la compétence le manque d'intérêt
par exemple des journalistes d'une
rédaction qui considère que une
révélation qui n'aurait fait ne va pas
intéresser le public n'est pas dans
l'air du temps ne présente pas un
intérêt quelconque
le deuxième mode de régulation c'est le
secret katie ve ment qu'est ce que le
gouvernement ou une autorité définit
comme étant secret pour des questions de
sécurité nationale
mais il y en a deux autres il ya et
c'est ce que disait monsieur montrer ya
quelques instants il y avait peut-être
d'abord la régulation culturel qu'est ce
qui est acceptable ou pas dans une dans
une société
et puis à la régulation économique et
elle n'est pas seulement liée aux
entreprises moi je viens à la fin de la
guerre froide et à la fin du conflit au
cambodge est dans ces pays qui
découvraient et finalement la démocratie
voire des dizaines de partis politiques
des dizaines de journaux naître avec
effectivement certains des des propos
très mesurés d'autres des propos
totalement fantasmagorique insultant et
puis la régulation c'est fait
au fur et à mesure soit parce qu'il ne
vendait pas sont tout simplement parce
que des intérêts économiques des
rachetés et les neutraliser et cette
liberté d'expression que cette liberté
de la presse même si les les deux choses
sont légèrement différents elle est
souvent ribul éparses et je dirais par
ces quatre éléments qui rentrent en
conflit avec avec cette liberté que
chacun voudrait promouvoir avant
[Musique]